[Music]
in furry fetish news burry I used to
think that word fetish was pronounced
feet-ish for some reason I'll like do it
ya betta submitted by sub-zero Oh the
old school Mortal Kombat good care
change really well developed character
especially in the movies
a Connecticut councilman has resigned
after his secret furry lifestyle is
revealed oh that's so sad why would you
want to rely Kree sign off of that oh I
[ __ ] love furry [ __ ] specifically
because we talked about it on news and
people are so mad me why yeah they were
like how dare you not all people who
like furry stuff a butler or sexually
perverse like you [ __ ] freak shut
someone not all people like furry [ __ ]
are weird it's like ya know that's
that's what you are there's a there's a
non-sexual furry group that just enjoy
the cosplay but there's also like the
sexual group that's a that's cosplay
though birdies are a different subset
cosplay is something else you're just
dressing up to be something you're not
you know this is like I want to [ __ ] you
as a teddy bear while you're a giraffe
you know babe
that's so that's the [ __ ] that we are
talking nobody's put it to me like that
before that's pretty cool yeah a new a
new thing for you India that's not bad
hey sell me some funny she's like saying
um if you like anime you like hentai
anime yeah so this up connecticut
councilman is resigning after his
profile on this website called so furry
calm hi what is exposed so his name is
Scott Chamberlain that seemed out of
costume he's not in costume a real
typical politician name headshot this
and it says know your candidate the real
Scott Chamberlain
let's like the JK office what the [ __ ]
premier doesn't yeah so here's his the
website is a photo of him next to a
furry and then like his whole profile
where he's a boy this is a scandal that
[ __ ] the [ __ ] uh Ted Cruz where he
tweeted out the [ __ ] oh yeah the porn
link that [ __ ] was tight ray Oh Ted Cruz
like this is great I was like you know
what this [ __ ] watch you're a
person yeah anything else but that's why
he's even more of a person we would do
the same thing like I don't hate the guy
for watching some damn porn no prefer
that you do it's funny though because he
had done like he was for banning sex
toys and [ __ ] like he's like all trying
to pretend that he's holier than thou
wait wait wait what does porn have to do
with sex toys maybe he doesn't use to
exploit yeah thank you it's very
different
well apparently that that that video
that he liked was about some like a wife
secretly masturbating to her husband
having sex he's just a weird [ __ ] and
they were like all that that seems like
that's the [ __ ] he'd be into who can
view all I think he's just like corner
the market on sex toys so he could just
sell it on the black market for a lot
higher yeah I love it
or he's just wants his wife to stop yeah
back to this dude Scott he was saying
that this entire thing with his
association with the furries it's not
anything sexual it's just that he has an
appreciation for animal characters like
Tony the Tiger and Mickey Mouse sure you
do that's a scariest thing I've ever
heard yeah the tiger right an
appreciation that's like someone saying
I like to buy Playboy magazine for the
articles not for the women
yeah that's not true no they're not you
got lied to cuz you could read article
somewhere else
doesn't that playboy now they don't have
naked pictures now really in you they do
they bought a bath do they brought it
back back he brought it back cuz there
they'll drop their like alright nobody's
buying it I want to know who the [ __ ]
marketing genius was that you know
behind playboy how about like you know
what from now on no more immunity it's
the same idiots who are like our brand
is so strong it doesn't matter what we
do cuz everyone loves our brand like
they always buck up boom they're saying
that this dude he was in his profile he
had his avatar that resembles a fox
named grey muzzle so apparently that
might be his like furry identity great
puzzle gray muzzle muslin what what yeah
and so he's a fox or uh what is he a
[ __ ] yeah he's a fox a grey fox called
green money yeah
and so they were saying though in his
profile that it indicated they keep
tolerates rape and that made one of one
commenter question his ability to lead
so they're just saying like this is
because of his interest which then led
him to resign he tolerates rape yeah why
would that be like one of your profile
entries no it's because in that profile
they like there's a list of preferences
that ranges from loves to likes to
tolerates to hate in order to like go
right under it so right under dislikes
cucumbers he has tolerates rape and it's
like random facts that that's the actual
words that he used oh I want to hear
that operates rape he's like I think Ray
Skyy okay all these politicians are
scholars dude and your parents a
politician the parents are politicians
but they're just boring people when they
go home BDSM clothes and [ __ ] yeah
whatever you find out some crazy [ __ ]
about your parents what would you do no
I like that he goes home and his dad has
a ball gag and he's like hey Dad and
he's like my life is completely normal
like you're used to not used to it he's
doing here's the thing that shit's weird
there's like all my dad's here's
leathers who cares yes really
he doesn't know that's [ __ ]
ridiculous turns around to him a [ __ ]
drill cook up a hole the bog how you
breathe yeah he's like I had to feed my
dad last night you know dog food because
that's what my dad eats me there's a gas
when they're good boy you put a ball in
there there's obviously gaps son of a
politician knows but it wouldn't affect
you guys thank you it's let's say you
support this dude right you're into
politics no wonder I'm trying I think
I'd be more worried about the tolerates
rape than the furry thing yeah
care if he likes furry [ __ ] that's like
that's I mean what you do on your
personal time that's you know as long as
it's not hurtful or whatever like if
someone like says hey sometimes I like
to watch you know orgies and sometimes I
like to join orgies on my personal time
but how many hours are you doing that
for when they should be doing more
research further uh you know whatever
all it takes that hey dude if they're
watching porn they're probably at their
government job let's be real if we binge
watch like the next season of I don't
know like American Horror Story or
whatever we're not different they're
just they're just really into their
hobby
I'd rather have a politician that's like
passionate about something and have
hobbies or than a boring guy that just
does work all day I agree especially if
it's something funny I think it's even
better yeah if you're in the fridge yeah
if you're gonna eat [ __ ] right am I good
for you that's funny actually I like
that I trust ya
I trust them because they're like unique
you know so if you were a politician you
just come out and be like saw me today
something that I already do that right
now people love it no politician but
people want me to be people watch your
own country they want me to be present
all that stuff I don't know why
well I'm the king no I bike to that but
that evolved here when you guys asked me
like oh if you had a country whatever it
all it never came from me saying like oh
one day like everybody pumped me up to
believe like it's almost like William
Hung like back in the day they pumped
him up to believe that he could keep
singing and singing but they were just
making fun of them damn man that's what
happened now he's sucking dick for money
yeah it's terrible I'm sure we ought to
mean like now then they built them up so
hard and then he felt so hard like you
know he does motivational speeches it's
awesome i watch how he does on my bed
his motivational speeches yeah he works
for the police department doing some
kind of analyst stuff or I forgot what
it was but then um cuz he goes to my
barber so he gets a haircut from the he
lives around here yeah but I watch this
video of him doing like motivational
speeches and I was like oh this is
pretty charming it's you think you do a
good job at it
like yeah is it all religious like
Church no this is all seriously goes she
bangs no no or you just making fun of no
I'm just saying that would just sound
like it's like that's a great open ball
was that changed my rifle ever no he
talks about his like his rise to fame in
his fall and like how he came back up
from the fall and the depression and all
that stuff
he went to depression well yeah it's it
made photos but it's it's really
charming cuz he throws in some jokes and
it's stuff like that he's able to laugh
at himself but my Barbara goes I don't
like him he's mean to his fans and I'm
like yes fans so he does well they're
ironic fans that's why he's gotta be
mean to him yeah he doesn't like to take
pictures is whatever is it no picture no
no we saw we saw him at one of these
cafes down the street those either says
yeah yeah and we saw him and like all we
did was look at him and were like and
then his mom you stand right next to him
his mom was like and then I knew they
left the restaurant I just [ __ ] that
fool you're William [ __ ] home you're
not
Paul McCartney like what are you talking
I'm glad I made fun of them then the mom
pine thinks that you're gonna make fun
of them that's why she does her she's
protecting her son yeah that makes his
brand yeah yeah it's probably honestly
because he's really ugly yes he's you
cut up he was like physically Mutombo
his insides right but he is on the
higher spectrum of radio face and so
that's just radio voice radio for an
Asian guy he's just kind of like that he
looks like a racist cartoon exactly
that's that's what I'm trying to say
like it was any better he's like those
China phobia like yeah characters that
like oh be careful for this creature
yellow peril yeah yellow peril kind of
go it's a term used against
asian-americans like oh beware the
yellow invasion it was like in the late
1800s or something when it was like the
yellow scare but anyways I think that
that is he is he is that like if you
could take a picture of that and that
racist propaganda stuff and then you you
had previous Asian that guy really took
us back like he looks like world war two
like propaganda posters yes that's what
he looks like you know oh man but on the
other hand I will say this he made us
all happy for a long time I don't know
how this conversation turns away lemon
hey you guys want to stock any of us
we'll go ahead down to the description
box below and you can follow us on
Instagram and all kinds of stuff for
more videos
[Music]